in the light of early morning we watch
boat after boat arrived in the small
port of Schuyler suka meanness in the
north of lesbos women and children came
first transferred from an EU border
vessel too big to dock here these
Afghans had been rescued from a small
dinghy making a crossing from Turkey to
Greece and their relief is obvious to
see but in the days to come they may
question whether it was all worth it
that night we joined the Greek Coast
Guard on patrol the governor of the
north aegean islands which include
lesbos on board he wanted to see the
work being done to safeguard the lives
of migrants and asylum seekers heading
to Greece it's in this area the border
line between Turkey and Greece that the
vessel will spend the night searching
just five and a half miles separate the
two nations Turkey to the left Greece to
the right but out here in the dead of
night you get a real sense of the risks
people are taking and the governor knows
the reality that awaits those who make
it to his Ireland months possibly years
in grim camps living in conditions he
finds impossible to accept so for
I really feel ashamed as a European as a
Greek as a habitat a kind of this island
I feel ashamed for these people there
are poor people there people who
traveled a lot walked a lot they crossed
continents here they paid a lot of money
to Turks to be carried here to be
carried here and they live this life
he has seen the reality for himself he
visited the notorious Moria camp last
weekend after a fatal fire triggered
protests many living here described it
as hell a warren of tents and living
containers with raw sewage flowing
freely thirteen thousand people are now
living in space intended for just three
thousand and amongst them the young aid
agency say 40 percent of the population
here with children so this is all the
pediatric component so this is the
waiting area outside the camp workers
from the MSF medical charity cannot cope
with the number of children needing to
see them parents press against the gates
as doctors and nurses treat not just
physical problems but increasingly
mental health issues many children
scarred by war then by the months long
journey to get here
a further traumatized by Moria you have
small kids that they stop eating they
don't sleep they have tendency to
self-mutilation they have attempted
suicide this is horrible to see children
with this kind of condition and their
parents they are sharing with us their
feeling of guilty they feel guilty to
have brought their kids to this place
MSF is demanding children and the
vulnerable be transferred to mainland
Greece but progress is slow and has left
many questioning their choice to come
here like others Syed Ali spent
thousands getting here from Afghanistan
he's not sure it was the right decision
in here is not a better a bit better of
life in Afghanistan we haven't security
in Heroes - not security do you wish
you'd stayed in Afghanistan
maybe it's a question we heard many
asking here and some claim the Greek
government is using the grim conditions
as a deterrent for now though the
migrants still come in hope and only
believed the reality when they see it
Michelle Clifford Sky News lesbos Greece